[Music]
the guy all right what's on the menu top
five ways to increase confidence okay
all right let's do this
so you might be wondering why I'm
drinking coffee even though I'm the guy
who made a video about why you should
stop drinking coffee or caffeine in
general how to quit caffeine and why you
might want to am I slightly hypocritical
yes but I also just finished exam season
and I was talking back coffee to have
those like peaks of energy to help me
get through the papers and it helped
quite a bit but now that I'm not on
exams anymore or doing exams anymore I
am tapering off so
I guarantee you if you follow these tips
you'll become much more confident of a
person and these tips are not quick
fixes these are these are strategies and
each thing on this list will take you a
really long time to get straight but
once you actually do attain these you'll
notice that you will be a lot more
confident of a person these tips took me
years to develop and I'm still not
perfect at them but I can guarantee you
they're life-changing so the most
important thing you need to do by far to
increase your confidence is to create
strong values and live according to them
if you were to get your values from
today's contemporary culture your values
would be like look hot get rich have sex
they're terrible values because they
won't make you happy they may make you
temporarily experience pleasure for a
short amount of time but if you live by
those who knows what so how does one
come up with better values okay so I was
editing this part of the video and I
thought I'd redo this whole section
because I didn't like it so if you have
crappy values you need to have better
values and you need to live by those
better values but saying just have
better values it's such a subjective
thing and I can't tell you what good
values are that's up to you but you
probably already have a good idea of
what your higher values are when you
perform an action or do anything that's
aligned with your higher values you will
feel empowered you'll feel good about
yourself and your self-confidence will
improve you know things like telling the
truth or sticking up for somebody or
sacrificing what you want now for what
you want most you know these things are
often not easy to do but once you do
them you feel really powerful and you
feel really good about yourself things
that go against your higher values may
feel pretty good at the time but they
will disintegrate you they'll make you
feel worse about yourself so just
basically meditate and reflect on what
your higher values are what are those
things that are higher truths to you
kind of you're your moral compass and
align your actions and your decisions
based on those values and stick to them
no matter what nothing is a bigger
confidence killer than doing something
that contradicts your values whether
it's for somebody else or whether it's
just a moment of weakness and you
do it just you know to experience
pleasure you know when you do something
that you don't really want to do but you
do it out of weakness you don't feel
very good about yourself or if you do
something that contradicts your values
for a employer or somebody like that you
don't feel very good about yourself you
feel really slimy and that is a huge
confidence killer it ruins your opinion
of yourself and you just won't be that
rock-solid confident dude that this
video is trying to teach you how to be
okay number two is to choose the few
people whose opinion you care about and
forget everyone else if you listen to
contemporary wisdom you would read lots
of books saying you shouldn't care about
what anyone thinks of you I disagree
with that for a lot of reasons I think
there are many benefits to actually
caring what other people think of you
just not everybody most people the
majority of people you come across you
should not care about what they think of
you so how do you figure out whose
opinion does matter who will help you
achieve your core values who will build
you up as a person what kinds of people
will help you be the best version of
yourself these are the people whose
opinion matters other people whose
opinion you can care about our close
friends and if you're a value based
person you will choose your friends
according to who will help you stick to
your values you're gonna choose friends
who actually have something going on
have their life together and are
constantly you know improving themselves
and building towards something and will
help you build towards something if you
have deadbeat friends who are dragging
you down doesn't you don't have to care
about them anymore as a human being you
know check in with them see how they're
doing but I have plenty of people in my
life who if I was still hanging out with
them I would not be where I am today and
finally other people whose opinion you
should care about our mentors and the
nice thing about mentors is you can
choose who is your mentor you can choose
your mentors you can have several
mentors these can be spiritual mentors
professional Mentors these can be
mentors at the gym who are more jacked
than you and you want to figure out how
to be as jacked as them these are people
who are further along in certain aspects
of life than you you are the product of
everyone you surround yourself with so
if you're surrounded with people who are
better than you you have no choice but
to get as good as those people so those
are the people whose opinion you should
care about
so forget everyone else and that might
not sound very practical it's like how
do I stop thinking about what everyone
thinks of me good question you read the
book how to stop worrying and start
living by Dale Carnegie peeps I was
right Dale Carnegie it's the same author
of how to win friends and influence
people and another piece of advice that
I have to you that will help you stop
worrying about what other people think
of you is realize how seldom they do
people are not thinking about you
you think that people are thinking about
you because you're all tied up and you
know the social interactions you just
had no one's thinking about you it's
morbid people think of you every once in
a while if you do something really cool
if you make an impact on them positively
but by and large people are thinking
about themselves it's a sad reality but
everyone's thinking about themselves
realize that and you'll have power tip
number three to increase your confidence
is to affirm yourself and this doesn't
mean that you have to talk to yourself
in the mirror every morning before you
brush your teeth it just means that you
should really watch the kind of
self-talk that goes inside your head
when you mess up are you the kind of
person who berate to yourself or you're
the kind of person who is sympathetic
towards himself and you realize that
you're on your own side this was one of
the most powerful techniques that helped
me become more confident in every aspect
of my life watching how I responded to
myself when I did something that either
violated my values or if I messed up you
know in a job or something like that did
I put myself down or was I realistic
realize that I made a mistake
and helped myself not make that mistake
again because I loved myself your
opinion of yourself is the cornerstone
of confidence if you know that you're
human you make mistakes and you're
allowed to make mistakes you will worry
a lot less about making them tip number
four have a purpose I can't tell you how
to have a purpose you don't need to
figure out the meaning of life or
anything like that all I'm saying is you
need to have a reason for waking up
every morning if you have a goal say
like a five-year plan you want to get
out of student debt you want to start
developing passive income so that you
have the freedom to spend time with
people that you care about that is a
purpose and if you stick to that and you
fully buy into that goal
then you have a rock-solid reason for
waking up in the morning and you have
something that'll help guide every
action of your life and that will
inspire confidence this kind of purpose
makes every interaction you have with
every human being means something this
guy who walks into a room everyone shuts
up they look at him like a celebrity
right they got mad clout they walk
around like they have a purpose if you
ask any successful person what he's
doing today or what he's doing next week
or what the overall plan is for the
month they will be able to tell you
that's in part why they're so confident
they know exactly what they need to do
and they don't really care about anyone
who stands in the way of that so figure
out what your purpose is and you'll
instantly have way more confidence tip
number five and this is the only kind of
classic listicle tip I have on here is
act confident even if you're nervous if
you walk around like you're going
somewhere it automatically you know your
release testosterone and serotonin or
something I don't know read your
Peterson's book rule number one in
Jordan Peterson's 12 rules for life is
stand up straight with your shoulders
back
not just Jordan Peterson knowledge if
you look up if you google power posing
if you stand up okay maybe I'm just
gonna do it all right all right that's
power posing your physiology is directly
and intimately linked with your
psychology if you have a habit of having
kind of a crappy posture and you walk
around and you know you're kind of
walking around aimlessly then you are
gonna produce the brain chemicals that
makes you feel like a beta male makes
you feel subhuman you're not gonna feel
very good at all whereas if you just
adjust your posture you breathe deep and
you act confidently you will be more
confident so really be mindful of how
you're dressing how you're walking how
your posture is how you present yourself
on a physiological level because it
directly influences your psychology and
vice-versa fake it until you make it as
powerful if you want to be confident
start pretending to be confident so by
following this advice you'll be
come the most confident person you know
the most confident person that anyone
knows when you walk into a room people
will stop talking
someone will work up the courage to ask
you for your autograph you'll sign it
sign there or whatever they're gonna
look you up online that will find
nothing it's because you faked it and
you made it anyways I don't really know
if you liked this video hit that like
button if you liked videos like these in
general hit that subscribe button
there's also a bell icon if you don't
hit that Bell icon you will have no idea
when I post the video even if you're
subscribed to me so if you want to see
videos like these ever again hit that
Bell icon that way you'll be notified
when I post a new video also joining the
Facebook group is a no-brainer so if you
haven't joined the Facebook group join
the Facebook group the link is in the
description the main feature of that is
that you get to talk to like-minded
people that will help build you up it's
like the mentorship thing I was talking
about you'll also get to vote on new
videos I will post kind of like certain
video topics it'll be a poll you get to
vote on the poll or suggest new video
topics that you want to see it is
basically the inner circle of better
ideas so if you want to be a part of
that hit that description hit the link
in the description and yeah have a good
time thanks for watching and we'll catch
you in the next video